NapoleonCat is a social
media marketing dashboard.
I co-founded the
company four years ago.
And a year ago, I took
over the CEO position.
Switching to CEO means that
you are the person that
has to implement the ideas,
and put them into practice,
and make them work.
And you are the one
that is responsible
for the actual effects.
And you are also responsible
for the whole team
on a daily basis.
So that puts much more pressure
and responsibility on a person.
The beauty of such a
solution is that you actually
don't have to be present
in different countries,
physically, to
sell your products,
and to have customers,
and to serve them
all over the world,
because you can do it all
online from the office in
Warsaw, Brazil, wherever.